look who's in the man cave Michael Smith
Jamel Hill or is it Jamel Hill and
Michael Smith your name always comes
first for some reason a lot only because
it was his and hers so it bonded but
maybe we should have switched it for the
six maybe someday
maybe you should all donate it ladies
first yeah but like each day we all know
who carries the other one Sports Center
six its SC six with a Michael and Chanel
it premieres Monday as the sex you
believe that how many years would it
calm it to six internally yeah yeah yeah
now we taking the public espn2 we called
it the deuce we had an interoffice memo
that says stop calling it the do's went
really yeah because that's what people
still identified as being the do so as
you know everybody on campus in the
office they call it the six so we like
why don't we just call it the six I like
it but unfortunately we have people who
think we're copying trick yeah they were
born in like nineteen ninety eight and
I'm just like hey he did not invent the
numeral six just so you know because the
six is referring to Toronto and this are
you sure that Drake doesn't think he
invented the number six
I think it's fancy did you know this is
just I'm glad that we got the
opportunity to clear that up because so
people won't think we're biting how did
this partnership come up you know we
just used to spend a lot of time
together when Jamel would come up and do
things like sports reporters or and you
know I will commute from Massachusetts
to do different things and you know we'd
hang out and and realize that a lot of
our conversations just had this they
always take an interesting turn to
relationships to life to you know social
issues whatever we like man you know
this would be pretty cool of people to
hear we think or if nothing else they'd
be fun to work together so people
weren't falling over himself to put us
on television but Sarita Johnson shout
out to Sherita entrusted us with a
podcast in 2013 after the Super Bowl
xlvii we started the his nurse pocket
and four years later here we are
but Michael and Tony started out that
way you know but they were working both
with the Washington Post so you had
writers you know obviously one black one
white different social backgrounds here
or a different
opinions love to argue and I remember
when mr. Toney said can you believe
they're gonna put this on TV
and and he was so nervous about he goes
that nobody's gonna watch this
no one's gonna watch this and I said if
they allow you to be yourself yeah then
it'll be great because if you around
Michael and Tony they would go at it
yeah and then and then they would stop
like they they were tomorrow like they'd
argue and then they'd make up yeah you
know so I don't know if that's the way
we actually go back to 2002 yeah we met
as writers and it's funny you say that
because we were arguing about LeBron and
yes we do have one but not in general
you know it's funny you should say that
because see optically Tony and Mike are
different instance as you said black guy
white guy but really the same dude but
really they're the same dudes and to
some degree we sort of face a certain
stereotype because we're both like sort
of close in age you know both black and
even though there's a gender difference
obviously I think there was this kind of
just automatic assumption that we
probably thought the same but we are
we're like minded but we think
differently that make sense well someone
say we share a brain you know but I
think that's because it's same thing
with Keith and I we we didn't have much
in common we didn't hang out socially
but when you got on the air we
understood what the other person thought
and so you complement each other without
even trying to do that but we actually
do hang out a lot it's kind of like it's
kind of scary the other day Jamel told
me that she talks to me more than
anybody and Janelle is in a very
committed relationship at the moment and
she says you know cuz I always catch it
when she's about to take off on a plane
just like you always call me when I'm
about to take off and you know we talked
on the phone more than anybody because
it's and it's not just you know in
social conversations or you know
informal conversations about what hey
what are you doing what's going on
did you watch this episode of
such-and-such show we're constantly both
thinking about the show and how to
improve it like you know what happened
today what could we do better what do we
do better for tomorrow did you see Dan
Patrick show did you see how they
approach this topic so we're so
dedicated to you know equally dedicated
to improving it until you'll never hear
me
going to the media saying but but having
trust with each other it's the most
important thing you could have yeah
whether it's greenie and Golic or Tom
Jackson Chris Berman myself and Keith
there is something about that that if
you need something or you need bailed
out if that you can see it in the other
person's eyes of Wayman did I go down a
road I didn't need to go can you help me
get back having that trust is is
probably the most important factor that
you can have with the relationship like
because you're doing live TV and that's
different
you're doing live TV have you gotten
anything that you did on his and hers or
put myself a timeout to say yeah you did
earlier I've cussed why so a lot of TV
yeah just yeah well the first time I got
too comfortable the second time I was
really angry and that's look I go back
15 years in the business never did it
I'm not proud of it I mean I'm not
bragging about it by any means the first
time it was just caught up in the moment
and everybody laughed at it I was
embarrassed and I thought I was gonna
suspend it she laughed up behind off
we're happy because what you said you
thought you gonna be the first one okay
I thought it would be second time we
having a really serious conversation and
it kind of slipped out in that in a
moment of anger and look the viewers in
every problem with it because they
understood where I was coming from and I
went to I went to the office I'm like
I'm sorry
like don't worry about it but I'm not
crazy enough to think that two strikes
are that's all my record right I can't
do that on this and I'm mad at him
because now I can't curse No right so I
like if I let one slip it'll probably I
probably have to pay for your strikes
yes I want to talk to you guys about the
philosophy of the six and and what is
going to be different do you feel like
you have to make something different and
that you're looking at the six o'clock
growing up watching it or Sports Center
in general of what it's supposed to be
and the freedom that you guys may have
also want to ask you about some other
things going on what's going on with
LeBron
you know this social media of the role
that it's playing here the Carmelo
situation I talked
about Brady and Belichick Phil Jackson
and in Michael Michael Jordan what's
more impressive with a star in a coach
combo the role that politics could play
at the Super Bowl with Tom Brady and
Bill Belichick asking about Donald Trump
if that does play a role at all because
we have two teams one is by design bland
and the other one I think is just bland
without personalities here so we'll
continue there are the new stars of the
six
it's Michael Smith Jamel Hill or as I
like to say Jamel Hill and Michael Smith
we're back after this discuss it's known
as the six it'll be a Michael Smith
Jamel Hill and it starts after the
Superbowl Monday February 6th at 6:00
Eastern I will say I did question that
logic I would had you started at the
Super Bowl I think that would have been
a better stage for you than the week
leading up yes yes okay yeah I think
part of the thinking was because they
are redesigning the studio in a unique
way compared to the other sports centers
I think they wanted kind of our first
show to be at home so to speak so but I
mean that's a valid point about you know
the Super Bowl and the eyes the
attention the level of guests obviously
we know you could get a Super Bowl a
little bit well we also just ended his
and hers like last week but we had to
kind of finish that out a little bit and
so we needed as much time as we could to
try to get this right we're not
overhauling what we do fundamentally
yeah philosophically but there are some
adjustments and you know new staff and
that sort of thing so we need time to
get it right we want to hit the ground
running as best we can
how do you change how do you is is it
subtle changes of what you're trying to
do or is it going to be another I mean I
guess it just depends on who people
think the 6 p.m. Sports Center viewer is
yeah because for us it won't be a
fundamental change because we are
bringing this the essence of the same
show to the 6 like it won't be a
highlight driven show it will be a
conversation driven show so is it debate
uh we're never did we were never debate
we were discussion yeah yeah right
there's a difference yeah where's the
difference well that's that's one
different
but no it doesn't have to be debates
don't have to be loud you embrace debate
you hug discussion suggest that it needs
to be a winner or a loser and we're not
up to win or lose when we talk to each
other I'm not trying to show her up
she's not trying to show me I'm not
trying to prove her wrong or vice versa
we're just listening to each other's
viewpoints and we could agree to
disagree move on
so debate just seems like it also I
think there's a connotation of being
staged debate makes it harder for people
to believe that you're authentically
disagreeing sometimes people will think
if there's a debate or you're just
saying that to disagree with her because
you think that's we want to see I think
that's more credibility in hugging
discussion as you put it but I was just
going to say yes how are we going to
change I was gonna wait till the end but
you know wait what no no to say and I
told us - jamele now and I want to thank
you you're on the show one of the first
phone calls we got when it was announced
that I got was from a number that I
didn't have locked in my phone when the
show was announced today we gotta take
over the six was from you from Dan
Patrick and I just appreciated you
taking the time to do that congratulate
me and us by extension he just didn't
have your number Jamel and you know you
were among the first vets my vets one of
the first vets of SportsCenter to say
don't change Mike if you got here to be
honest it was a pant style I didn't mean
to call you we had a conversation Super
Bowl in Detroit yeah and you were asking
me what advice I would give to you hmm I
don't even know what I told what did you
say but you were curious and that's what
I loved if you're curious about how do
we do how do I fit what do we do what's
different what can we do what can I do
and I said you got to get reps you got
to get repetition you got to be on the
air yeah I remember saying that right
and this time do you remember what you
said this time you said don't don't let
those letters don't let the the platform
don't let it change you you know don't
let them change you know do you and know
here's the good news and this is a blow
your mind as somebody who you know
obviously you know was there at a
different time they have no designs on
training changing us the fact that they
asked us to do this and that's the key
part of it this was not our plan you
know
we were about a year out from our
contract meaning up we know they liked
us and wanted us to keep doing our thing
we were of the mentality that we were
just gonna be his and hers and and what
were the things that we needed to
improve that and the way he just kind of
happened was just it was very it caught
us by surprise I mean we were literally
standing in the middle of the ESPN
newsroom and Brock King who oversees
SportsCenter walked past us
then he doubled back and said hey you
know I got an idea they told me you guys
would say no and I just thought I would
just tell you what I was thinking anyway
and he was like what do you think about
hosting you guys hosting the six o'clock
SportsCenter now keep in mind we were
gonna fill in at various points just to
do it just for more publicity for our
show expanding our brand doing something
different just as Phil is and we were
like yeah you you know we we agreed to
that we would fill in he's like no no I
mean being the host and we actually
started laughing because we're not
anchors he's like and then he went into
a great pitch and a great sale and said
oh no we don't want you to be what you
know people have imagined the product
because poor Center has evolved a lot a
lot of people have maybe not notice but
it has they have moved away from
highlights in a lot of I'm in the
morning is different it depends on what
time you see what they've done what
Scott Van Pelt yeah you know they have
really embraced huge culture change so
he the more he started talking and
giving us the creative freedom very
similar to what we had on his and hers
as soon as he left and you know we had
agreed to meet with him in a more
thorough meeting or a bigger meeting and
Mike and I were like that really sounded
good that sounded like something we
could do so just by the fact that they
sought us out and recognized the things
that we that we done let us know right
away that they were ready for a abrupt
change it's good it's good and and I
think you can also report on something
in real time and then discuss something
in real time so you're almost gonna be
the person who reports on it and then
the analysts who discuss it which I
think if you're able to deliver your
news we're not gonna ignore breaking
news I mean we could we can switch at a
moment's notice in to anchor mo Jamel
jokingly says that were not anchors but
we we we're pretty proficient at that as
well Scott had me on his first show
I love the name like a foe ask would
have been nice Mike I just figured sorry
a couple of sports things now Donald
Trump's role with Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick if you guys were covering this
as let's say print media how important
would this be or if your reporters
covering this or you were doing your
first SportsCenter how important would
this be that topic if Brady's already
talked about it Trump's talked about
Bella checks talked about it Robert
Kraft's talked about it is it important
at all
leading up to Super Bowl I think it said
despite what Tom Brady says about he
doesn't understand why it's a big deal
and I think he's being a little
oblivious probably on purpose be given
that the Patriots they tried to be as
uninteresting as possible and he doesn't
want this story to go any further I mean
the fact of the matter is we have a very
polarizing person in office and that
person does not resist any opportunity
to bring up the fact that he knows Tom
Brady right and that he knows Bill
Belichick and they're good friends and
exactly and I think that it is should it
play a role we need to play a role in
the coverage yeah no not if you cover in
football okay but you know look it's
discussion worthy and Brady st. almost
being defensive and saying if he just
said you know guys I'd rather keep that
relationship private but to go and say I
don't understand why this is a big deal
and to avoid it and said but wait a
second man we're all judged by the
company we keep yeah there are certain
people especially in this day and age
you wouldn't take a photo with you know
like if trying to think of somebody
that's infamous right now I understand
he's you know the the president United
States and that's different so I'm not
trying to this is not apples to oranges
comparison I'm sure people will hate me
for saying this but Tom Brady wouldn't
take a picture of a Greg Hardy right now
no because of the things that are
associated with great party and I
understand that Donald Trump has not
done the things that Greg Hardy has been
accused of doing okay
however Donald Trump
said some things and perhaps done some
things that people find morally
questionable all right
so if you if that's your guy and you
have a hat in your locker that says make
America great again and you're hanging
out with him and he's shouting you out
of y'all are writing letters to man that
sort of thing people want to know that's
your boy because she judged by the
company you keep so are you like minded
in certain ways do you agree with him on
somebody's polarizing policies that he's
putting forth or some of the things that
he said you know is that what is that
how you think because Tom Brady to this
point deflategate aside and some
people's mind which has a whole nother
conversation has that a pretty pristine
image when it comes to character but
also the Super Bowl is covered by
mainstream media too so it may not be
normal mainstream sports outlets that
will ask this to try to get a reaction
right
also when a if I said Brady and
Belichick Michael Jordan and Phil
Jackson better better star coach combo
is it a fair comparison or would you
have to wait about nine more days I
think it's fair now I think the only
issue is just two different sports and
and that's kind of wild lean some more
tour Brady and Belichick just because
you know Michael had another all-time
great player in Scotty and another
all-time great player you would lean
towards Brady and Belichick is the best
yes coach just because of the turnover
around them just because of how hard it
is in this day and age to keep you know
I mean the guys on the floor yeah you
got Rodman you got a Pippen you know ya
feel obviously the offensive line is you
need move in and out the wide receivers
come and go I mean do you remember a
couple weeks ago when people wondered
where the losing crock would slow them
down you know so I in the defense guys
have come and gone and yet they've been
the constants so I'd have to lean to
what Brody yes I would have to lean
toward them to just and and look this
may be a little unfair but I think how
phil has handled the knicks is is on his
record and I do and because Bill
Belichick has personnel control right is
Cleveland or Bill Belichick record no
but I think it's enough distance from
that to prove that it wasn't just him
but isn't he the last coach to actually
you have like gone to the playoffs Brown
did once I think the new maybe treatment
okay
not in seven years something
nevertheless I think given that we're in
the free agency era in the NFL and how
hard it is to keep a team together and
the fact that he's one with so many
different pieces in so many different
ways he's a he's a I'm not saying this
to disrespect Phil because I think he's
a tactician in his own right but Bill
Belichick is truly a tactician in the
game and certainly I think at this point
the best coach in NFL history but also I
look at it as Michael was the best
player in the game Tom Brady's not the
best player in the game he's the
greatest quarterback of all time which
is it's it's apples so who's the best
third of game to you right now just
curious I don't consider I would have a
hard time saying he's the best player
okay he could be the most valuable but
you know is the position I'm looking at
Jordan with what he did offensively and
defensively he had to play both ways
Yeah right so Brady is just he's playing
offense right Jordan would guard you he
was a Hall of Fame defender as well but
I mean the sports are different in what
we have a suit but if you're saying
somebody is the best by far and away
Matt Ryan's gonna be the MVP mm-hmm you
have to be so far like you said JJ why
I'm sorry to interrupt you JJ Watt at
one point was so far and away the best
defensive lineman among Rogers a Brady a
quarterback you could only leave me out
bill David Johnson at running back you'd
argue Julio Jones Antonio Brown Odell
Beckham my receiver with you know but
certain positions guys are just far and
away the better player so I see what you
saying about Jordan it's had so much
distance between him and everybody else
will do this quickly with social meet
the passive aggressive nature of LeBron
James yeah don't get me started this was
mostly this was his most aggressive
though yeah cuz usually he was it it was
it was aggressive and then it was
passive like he he's usually passive
aggressive this time he was aggressive
passive then he walked it back a little
bit right yeah she's changing a little
bit look my issue with it Dan was it
wasn't his constant need and drive to
get better I respect that
I think the manner in which he did it
was wrong and
I think at this point given the fact
that that Cleveland they spent more
money than any NBA team in the last
three years they lost 40 million last
year so they have to be held up there in
in a lot of ways all right
Tristan Thompson despite all his
limitations they paid them in part
because that's LeBron - yeah max no he
got maxed out right yeah we can debate
whether or not he's a max player hey
he's not Thompson stands before we card
a human okay so all that be given that I
think they deserve the right or earned
the right for LeBron to just have that
conversation in private no we didn't
need to know that and oh by the way it's
like so you're gonna convince me like
the 15th man it's gonna be the
difference between y'all winning a title
you just want to talk I just laugh
because it's kind of similar to what we
talked about in your green room it's
like nobody wants to hear rich people
complain about the tax break that they
didn't get or how to you know stay rich
and it's like you know people say oh we
look like CEOs we lost a million dollars
last year no you didn't make the million
that's projected you were gonna make it
didn't lose a million dollars I get
people are trying more than any other
well but and that's to me the
interesting thing whether you appreciate
him or you know don't appreciate him
going public with it or not I'm sure he
has had private conversations he's
looking at there's an empty roster spot
on the back end and there's to trade
level trade exceptions that they have
not used taking advantage of the
interesting thing about the story I
think was Brian were in Horace and our
place at ESPN if there was an
understanding between he and Dan Gilbert
that money was never going to be an
object and I get that they spent more
than anybody the last four years in
record-setting payroll but if you were
never gonna cut corners and money was
not going to be an object that's
interesting because now he has maybe an
out to say you went back on our
agreement over the 15th man interesting
maybe your son could be the 15th Michael
Hill Sports Center six o'clock it'll be
premiering Monday February 6th at 6:00
Eastern I wish you nothing but success
thank you have appreciated again thank
you for the call highlights to this
entire process your well carry on your
tradition as best we can old boy
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience